I really came I was like oh this is a
bad commute take me a longer time than
usual I think this morning I'm probably
late
hey everyone my name is Matt bellezza
and this is whine about it a weekly
video series where I get drunk at my
desk and complain about stuff on this
week's episode types of co-workers that
are the absolute worst let's drink
because house my go get tub do you want
me to sip it slowly no it's not chilled
alright first of all there's always that
one lumpy ball sack who tries to chat it
up in the [ __ ] bathroom I have to be
around your dusty vanilla face eight
hours a day five days a [ __ ] week for
like ever
for the love of God do not talk to me
while I am in the bathroom do not touch
me do not look at me do not breathe at
me why don't we just why we just make a
rule no talking to me well anything is
entering or exiting my body alright
let's just make that a rule next there's
always that one co-worker who's always
trying to use my mug or touches my desk
or steals my pets I don't know if you
know this but some pens are better than
other pins I'm sorry you chose the [ __ ]
pens in life I chose the good pens you
have to live with your shitty decisions
I guess my Winnie the Pooh pen just my
missing the same day that you got a new
one coincidence
now everyone steals my pens just like I
steal my soul piece-by-piece
every good day next there's that one son
of a [ __ ] who's always trying to make
everyone feel bad with the old
passive-aggressive note whoever's been
eating my Oreo snack packs please stop I
have low blood sugar and I need them
shut up Sharon nobody gives a gorilla's
nut about your Oreo snack packs yeah I
ate them we all a.m. we pass them around
every day they're delicious you got
something to say about your Oreo snack
packs why you come say it to my
chocolate crumb covered face so right
around a little post-it note you think
Abraham Lincoln use a post-it note to
free the slaves no he did it he talked
about his problems out loud like an
adult well there's that one co-worker
who's just always chatting it up on the
phone right at their desk where I'm for
everybody
Carol you're never gonna believe who I
saw ordering the unlimited appetizers
down at the thank God it's Friday
this is a place of business not the ball
pit out of Chucky Cheese there are rules
here like shut the [ __ ] up that's rule
number one
when we try to follow them that one
right at your desk with your little
phone okay
okay next is that person who takes work
way too seriously
sorry I don't staple my paper is a
perfect 90-degree angle sorry I only
look at butts all day instead of doing
my job sorry I got spaghetti sauce all
over the copy room for the third time
this week we're all just here trying to
get paid am i right we're all just we're
all just trying to turn hard work into
chicken nuggets am i right all right
everybody just needs to calm the [ __ ]
down
next there's the one shitstain who's
always later late every single day we
always have a different excuse sorry I'm
late I have a scratch of my throat
that's what I say I have a scratch of my
throat we all know who was in your
throat last night we saw those Instagram
photographs Jennifer finally reply-all
emails you think everybody cares about
your opinion you know sort of female the
[ __ ] everybody you reply to every
person on the email list don't you ever
in here apply all heap of sucking dick
munching all right everybody thank you
for watching this week as always you can
find our videos every week at
whineaboutit.tumblr.com and my page
which is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt
that's everything that's a piece of [ __ ]
I do everything a tape I write memos
they eat sandwiches at crime the
bathroom that's the fall day that's my
whole day